ще 8 місяців тому Оксана здивувалася б
якби дізналася що буде їздити щоранку на
роботу з дармштада у Франкфурт поїздом
компанії Deutsche Band і ще більше
здивувалася б якби дізналась що в цій
компанії і працюватиме на
франкфуртському вокзалі в бюро з
працевлаштування куди приходять
здебільшого іноземці такі ж як і вона
Оксана родом із Києва у перші дні війни
вона знайшла притулок у Німеччині
лёгкая поездка Це була нелегка поїздка
достатньо нелегка але щойно Ми перетнули
кордон Німеччини нам допомогли Нас
провели нам показали нас зустріли і
чесно кажучи заспокоїли тепер Оксана
працює на вокзалі у франкфуртій і
допомагає здобути впевненість та спокій
тим хто пройшов цей шлях після неї В
каждого із нас знову прибывших у кожного
з нас новоприбулих є дуже велика страх і
нерозуміння ситуації що відбувається
коли люди приходять і чують що до них
звертаються знайомою для них мовою чи
російською чи українською вони трохи
розслабляються вони можуть спокійно
обговорювати теми вони можуть розкритися
як професіонали вони можуть розкритися
як люди варіантів працевлаштування на
німецькій залізниці достатньо компанія
Deutsche Band один з найбільших
роботодавців Німеччини у списку вакансій
приблизно 500 спеціальностей і три такі
центри з працевлаштування у Франкфурті
Берліні та лейпцигу відкрили кілька
місяців тому саме з розрахунку на
українських біженців України
з-поміж українських біженців які
залишили країну з початку війни ми вже
змогли взяти на роботу 46 людей різних
професій наприклад зараз нам потрібні
співробітники для сфери громадського
харчування у поїздах робітники та
електрики але ми також шукаємо нових
співробітників у галузі продажів двері
широко відчинені проте наскільки
справжні українці в роботі співробітники
центру оцінюють зокрема і завдяки Оксані
А зі спиною
Я просто захоплений Оксаною гієм
амбіціями внеском який вона робить і
силою яку вона має а також тим що за
дуже короткий час перебування в
Німеччині вона так багато чого навчилася
і вже добре нас розуміє
Оксана не тільки розуміє нову для себе
мову а й цілком успішно використовує її
в роботі адже вся документація сотень
запропонованих професій німецькою та ці
позиції називаються на немецком А так ці
позиції мають німецькі назви їхній опис
також німецькою і завдяки інтенсивному
курсу який також допоміг мені пройти
Deutsche Band я все це розумію приймаю і
можу вже брати участь у консультаціях в
консультаціях Однак не всі біженці
настільки цілеспрямовані як Оксана і не
всі володіють спеціальності ми
затребуваними на залізниці саме тому тут
також приймають фахівці з Федеральної
агенції працевлаштування вони пропонують
вже не сотні вакансій а десятки тисяч
У нас дуже великі можливості для
підтримки та консультації людей ми тут
саме тому що добре доповнюємо пропозиції
роботи до ечебан оскільки можемо також
консультувати з інших питань та надавати
інші вакансії вже понад місяць бюро
працевлаштування Deutsche Band відкрито
не лише для українських біженців а й для
всіх хто шукає роботу шахабхан родом із
Пакистану він хотів би влаштуватися
провідником чи офіціантом вагона
ресторану
я звернувся сюди додо чи банджобленд
тому що в співробітники центру дуже
доброзичливі та готові прийти на
допомогу якщо ви не знаєте як знайти
роботу в Німеччині тут вам можуть
допомогти
щодо Оксани то роботу до душі в компанії
Deutsche Band вона вже знайшла і
сподівається що Німеччина стане її новим
домом та місцем де для неї відкриються
нові професійні горизонти